all right everybody we're back joey
lauren adams coming up
and uh we're gonna have a great show
with robert guillema i'm sorry uh
i before we go on i just wanted to point
out we got a
special guest in the audience tonight
i'm sure you remember my my little
sister stacy
oh yeah no i remember of course i
remember
there she is
that's great hiya hi there stacy
hi coney
by by the way she still has a huge crush
on you
andy you weren't supposed to say that
stacy come on it's cute
and she's she's wearing her new
christmas sweater for you
oh my god andy i'm like blushing to
infinity
stacy come on it's it's cute yeah it is
cute stacy you look very pretty in your
new sweater
you really think so i sure do
well i also have another new christmas
sweater that i wore at my new year's eve
party
really yeah she she made all the
decorations herself and
well she said she sent you like a
special invitation maybe
yeah i know i do it was very sweet of
you to invite me stacy i'm sorry that i
couldn't come to your party
she was a little disappointed no it
wasn't andy
it wasn't like i expected cohen to show
up or anything
well i don't know
stacey i mean well actually we have a
photo of that i took at the height of
the party
um
because she she she actually didn't
invite anybody else
okay andy you need to tell him that okay
because now conan thinks i'm like the
countess
of loser vania no no i
i don't think that stacy i think you're
a very sweet and pretty young lady
you do sure i do and i'm sorry that i
already had plans for new year's eve
you know i mean after our show here i
had to go meet my girlfriend
she was making dinner for me whoa whoa
whoa hold up
did you say you had to meet your
girlfriend
what are you talking about you knew i
had a girlfriend didn't you stacy
no i didn't andy failed to mention that
he said the reason you couldn't come to
the party was because your mom was sick
and you were visiting her in the
hospital
you did oh yeah he did
apparently andy thinks that his sister
is unworthy of the truth
well the fog has lifted
and now i know you two for what you
really are
cruel beasts trapped in a wretched cage
of
lies
stacy stacy
stacy look i'm sorry i just didn't want
you to get hurt shut your heart
pinocchio
or i'll shred you like a watergate memo
now how much do you even know about it i
don't want to know what you want
ryan i have wasted my last tear
on your sorry pink ass
wait a minute
my what you better sleep with one eye
open tonight mr talk show
because just because the year is new
doesn't mean my rage isn't ancient
and it will rise like a phoenix from the
and descend upon your freckled flesh
with this mighty sharp claws of
vengeance
stacy just please did he just calm down
stacey i'm i'm i'm sorry conan coney can
i help
ladies and gentlemen it's it's it's our
prop master bobby bowman bobby
yeah when i was stacy's agent feeling
bad nothing made me feel better than a
nice cup of hot chocolate
oh come on bobby this is good just a
second just a second
honey how about it would you like a nice
hot chocolate
with marshmallows yes just for you
thanks a lot mr bowman you can call me
bobby
bobby do you have a girlfriend
actually i have a wife sweetie then why
are you wasting my time off
i'm sorry
[Applause]
stacy please just keep coming stacy calm
down
i love you we're gonna we're gonna take
a break we'll
be right back
you